you
Jacob is my name and I'm a developer at
heart definitely but I'm also an
entrepreneur I've started a couple of
companies worked at a couple of startups
and so on and I'm generally like a crazy
person because I don't think anyone
saying would actually keep doing that
so what I'm into anyway is only startups
and lean and agile and XP and TDD and
pair programming and all those things
you know it and you get kind of
desperate at times when you want to work
24/7 24/7 and there's no one else around
so you start to pair up with whoever's
whoever's there and I've been doing like
different types of work I used to work
at the big data company in Sweden called
Burt which deals with a lot of data for
being a start-up and then I went on to
do kind of a small data start-up where
we dealt with very little data instead
I've also done some consulting with a
couple of friends for for other startups
and for VCS and so on and currently I'm
working at a company called fish brain
which helps sports fishers to catch more
and bigger fish so you guys look at and
I'm from I'm from Sweden and by the way
how many people in here have have been
to Sweden like very few like three or so
so I guess all of you kind of have an
idea of Sweden and I bet it's a lot like
this
like everyone thinks we're all like
butch men wearing heavy furs and always
talking about the fact that winter is
coming but it's it's not like that it's
worse it's more like this so yeah
miserable and what do Swedes do then
well we we stay inside we code that's
that's something we can do to stay away
from the cold and and some people they
they do something else that that's
actually also kind of a passion of mine
which is music and in the city where I'm
from which is called Gothenburg and it's
on the west coast of Sweden we actually
pioneered a specific genre of music
called melodic death metal very Swedish
like we have to get this rage of this
cold out out somehow so as you can see
melodic death metal is like an extreme
sub-genre of heavy metal music and it's
centered around our city so I thought
before I start I just share some of my
culture with you guys so this is how
Swedish people get the rage out
yeah so if anyone actually knew what
song that was or what band please tweet
it to me and I will be very warm and
fuzzy inside
right okay okay um I'm not here to talk
about sweets or metal or snow and or
anything like that I'm here to talk
about CSS testing and how it's not just
a myth so the purpose of this
presentation is is not to show off tons
of code and and like show exactly what
I'm doing in particular but rather raise
the awareness of the tools that are out
there because there are actually quite a
few and also I want to give you some
inspiration to a new workflow which
could help you with these things but
before we dive into that I just want to
say something about declarative
programming which I'm sure most of you
know exactly what it is but just to make
sure everyone's on the same level and
this is one definition of it and
declarative programming is a programming
paradigm that expresses the logic of a
computation without describing the
control flow like functional very
functional programming and and how does
that apply to us as web developers
because I mean this is our domain and
this is what we do well obviously the
like core languages for the web HTML and
CSS are highly declarative you can't
control how a computation is that is
done you can only describe what you want
to achieve and then the browser will
take care of it all of it and that's
kind of cool right because then we can't
really screw things up it's made to be
exactly what you type in and you're
gonna get that thing and everyone's
happy right but that's not really the
case because as developers we keep
yelling more more all the time we want
better tools we want more advanced ways
of doing things we want to manipulate
manipulate everything so
when it comes to CSS people have of
course created solutions for that like
pre-processors like sass and less and
stylist and so on and we add all things
like variables and mix-ins and all kinds
of reuse and operations and everything
to make this language more powerful to
make it do exactly what we want but the
question I want to ask is are we like
really really making it easier to work
with CSS with these things or are we
just adding more complicated levels of
abstraction on top of what we already
have because I kind of feel like CSS is
a lot about writing and even these
pre-processors it's a lot about writing
like oh how can I I skip these extra
characters and how can I reuse this
function so I don't have to type it
again and so on but we're never really
talking about reading sure I mean it's
easier to read code that is shorter but
that's not really the whole picture so
when I look at a code base with a lot of
CSS like not something you've just been
working on for a month but something
that is a huge project that has lived
for a while I usually always see the
same thing when I like stare through the
code and and that's something like this
like a couple of developers writing away
into the sunset shooting their guns like
there's no real process there's no no
tools to make sure that you have high
quality in your CSS and there are a
number of like total anti patterns being
used when it comes to CSS it's it's a
whole lot easier to just add a new style
instead of reusing what's already there
because it's hard to find what you're
looking for you have thousands of lines
and you don't know exactly what classes
are intended to do the exact same thing
you want to do and even if you find one
that has the same attributes that you
want to apply on your Dom element you
cannot be sure that someone else wasn't
thinking about maybe adding something to
that later or so on so it's just a lot
easier to just add a new class and and
throw that thing onto your your own
elements and just as bad or maybe worse
unused Styles are like rarely removed
because there's like almost no reason
you don't know what pages the style
might be might be used on maybe maybe
the class names are generated
dynamically or and you don't really
break anything if you keep them there
they just live on and become like dead
code which you don't really know if it's
dead or not and you have no overview as
to how the different styles interact
it's just a flat structure at least
plain CSS is and you have to read all
through all of it in order to understand
all the ideas and then of course we have
all these things like form factors and
adaptiveness and responsiveness and
these things that makes things even
harder so if you test it in one browser
and you see that yeah well it's okay if
I remove this class I don't need it then
well what happens in all other
situations and all other devices and so
on so in my opinion CSS is like the the
true right only language we say that
about languages like Perl or whatever
but but CSS is like truly right only you
you can actually get away by just adding
new styles with stronger selectors and
just putting more [ __ ] into your code
base and I looked at Wikipedia like what
are they saying about the the concept of
write only languages and it says this in
computer humor computer humor a write
only language is a programming language
with syntax or semantics sufficiently
dense and bizarre that any routine of
significant size is too difficult to
understand by other programmers and
cannot safely be edited
this is computer humor this is the life
for a living this is not humor this is
for real this is exactly what CSS feels
like and if you feel differently please
tell me because then you know something
that I don't so code quality something
we all struggle with right and when we
talk about this if we let go of CSS for
a while like what do we mean when we
talk about code quality well obviously
kind of the opposite of what I was
already saying but in general we have
this functional quality like the thing
we have created this is fit for it's fit
to do what we intended to do we solve
the problem and the second type of
quality is structural quality the degree
to to which we have created this in a in
a structured way in a good way and
that's kind of the problem with CSS
because we can do we can achieve the
things we want to but the the way to get
there is kind of stupid and structural
quality can be broken down into like
reliability maintainability size
efficiency security and so on and many
of these doesn't really apply for CSS
size is not that much of a concern
honestly and efficiency well we don't
control that even but the reliability of
the code and the maintainability of it
how how do we control that in other
programming languages what should we
start applying in in CSS and the answer
is of course rather obvious because you
already know what I'm about to talk
about
so tests of course we need tests that's
what you do that's what you do to
maintain high quality and make code
understandable for other developers how
many in here do actually write tests for
your code and I mean any code not CSS
but code scaring leaf you then a lot of
you actually you have a have a lot ahead
of you but to me testing is is like the
only way to to start feeling like
about your program like you get the
feeling that you can change anything
move anything try anything just be like
the master of your codebase without
losing your mind and for those of you
who are not that into two tests then I
just want to want to look at the typical
like test-driven development flow so the
idea is that you write the test that
fails you can do it first you can do it
after you've written your code but the
if you're really test driven then you do
it first so you write the test to
describe something that you want to
achieve you haven't done it yet but
you're describing what you want to do
what you want to achieve and then when
you have that then you start
implementing code that will make this
thing work
and when it works then you can go back
and start eliminating redundancy like
optimize your code remove pieces that
are not needed share reuse parts of that
with other parts of your code and so on
and be certain that everything still
works so what about testing CSS then
because obviously we could start
thinking the same way about CSS but
there is one big problem and that's
coming back to this declarative thing
that CSS is not procedural you can't
jack into CSS and change the way it
works or test for some some particular
part of it you can only go directly from
the code that you have written to an
actual this visual result the browser
does magic in between and it's not yours
to touch but let's try anyway let's do
something because that's what's
interesting right so I'm gonna walk
through four different approaches quite
quickly hopefully and then try to try to
summarize what we can learn from from
looking at those and and two of them are
quite simple they're targeted at your
code and two of them are more advanced
aiming at
stting the actual visuals that you're
producing with your CSS code so first
one this is like super simple people
don't even think of it as a test and
it's it's the syntax checks that you can
do in your your editor hopefully like
you check whether or not the CSS you
have written is is actually valid is
this something that works and it's
typically done by a plug-in or an IDE or
person and obviously it just looks
something like this we have some
highlighting and something tells us
what's going on all of you are probably
already doing this and then the second
way to to check your code statically to
see what's going on is to use some type
of style guides and in combination with
linting so we we specify how we want our
CSS to be written like both since I
quickly like where should braces be how
how much should we indent our code and
and so on which is kind of trivial but
also semantically like what kinds of of
attributes should you not use together
or should you not combine in certain
ways to catch like common mistakes or
patterns that won't work in IE or
whatever and there are there are tools
for this for example this one called CSS
lint it's a lot like javascript linter
but it's for CSS and you can run it on
the web or you can download it and run
it on the command line I think it's a
node.js it's a node.js
implementation and you can specify your
own style guides or or use ones that
come with it as suggestions so the
reason why this is is good and I think
you should start using is that it's
totally easy to apply your totally I
guess you're already doing some kind of
static checking of your code like you're
compiling CoffeeScript or you're
compiling less and you're doing you're
doing anything on your JavaScript and
whatever you can just add this
into this and it prevents common and
anti patterns but the problem of course
is that it doesn't really test the end
result you can't know if if what you're
writing it even if it's correct even if
it's exactly the thing that you intended
when you wrote this style guide you
can't know that it looks the way you
want to and it's also quite useless
without the good set of rules and
they're like catch-22 with rules is that
unless you know what the problems could
be then you can't write the rules to
prevent it and if you know what the
problems are then you maybe you don't
need the style guide because you already
know what to avoid so it's it's more for
maybe like junior developers or when you
have a large team where you're not like
sharing the same hivemind so let's jump
onto the more like sophisticated
technologies the third one then would be
to to use screenshots to look at what
you're actually producing so you can you
can compare the look of the site before
you do some change and after and see did
it change the way I want it and do some
image diff between those two to see
exactly what happened and there are a
couple of tools for doing this one
particular one is called Huxley made by
Pete Hahn who's actually here today and
it's it's a tool for you you use it to
record a few steps in your app like I
click this thing I am through these
things and and so on and record what it
looks like and then you can play back
that later when you've changed something
to see did the right things change or
not and there are similar ones out there
as well like phantom CSS and and so on
but this is actually quite popular and
you can ask Pete all about it
and the good thing about screenshots of
course is that no change can sneak by
screenshots are the actual output that
we're after
that's pixel by pixel exactly the look
of of the thing we're creating and it's
totally implementation agnostic you can
use any language any any technology
whatever screenshots are screenshots
it's on on there but the negative part
of course is that it breaks on content
changes say that you have some element
of randomness in in your site you show
quote from a client for example on the
top and it loops between a number of
different quotes maybe it's not the same
when you reload or you have ads and the
ads are out of your control you can't
change them so you have to start like
looking at particular pieces of your app
and you you can't screenshot everything
because it's too fragile but it gets
complicated and you have to start
specifying it and it's it becomes messy
quickly and it yields lots of false
positives if you start comparing
browsers for example there are tiny tiny
rendering differences that you don't
really care about but that will break
screenshots because yeah it actually
looks a bit different
so you need some way to to filter out
what of these these dips are interesting
and which of them are not interesting so
quite some challenges there and I think
that's one of the motivations why people
ended up doing this fourth thing that
I'm going to talk about and that's
comparing styles directly in the Dom so
you walk through the entire Dom each and
every note and look at what what
particular styles are being applied to
this node and if it's the same styles
before and after a change then you know
that you haven't really you haven't
really changed anything you can't have
broken anything
and you you you compare these styles
that are in there to some expectation
for example something you had before or
by writing down like I want this thing
to be blue and one tool you can use for
doing this
it's called Hardy it's written by a
German guy called Simon and it's in a
very early version at this moment but
it's quite promising and he has been
working a lot on testing CSS so I think
this is definitely worth checking out
and as you can see down there it's a
node module so it's very easy to just
install it if you're already into
JavaScript which I guess everyone here
is and the thing you do with it is that
you you write very high-level
specifications of what you want your
site to be styled like maybe some of you
have actually seen cucumber before hands
up if you've seen it oh that's not a lot
I think it's more more popular in the
Ruby community but anyway cucumber is
it's a tool for writing specifications
in a natural language that you then can
process so you write something like this
like a given that I visit localhost then
the the P tags under section should have
the color 68 68 68 and this will be
checked and by Hardy that this is
actually the case and that's kind of
cool we're writing a test in the same
way as we're writing tests for
JavaScript or other parts of our
application but it's kind of tedious
right too to test one attribute on one
tag with this much text it would take
quite a lot of work to test everything
and also think about the fact that here
we're testing that particular styles are
being applied we don't know what it
looks like so we have no idea if this is
really what we want or not but just -
I'm coming back to this actually so just
to give you an idea of how cucumber is
typically used since there are a lot of
people who are not familiar with it you
usually do something like this like very
high level you say that this is a test
for seeing if the filter for our audio
books work so we say that given some
audio books in our collection when I
visit the list of audio books and search
for a particular term like core then I
only see the titles that are matching
and when I remove the filter then I see
all the audio books again so this is a
test that that you implement then using
cucumber you can go to the site and read
more about it if you're curious but this
is like typical acceptance testing we're
not unit testing pieces of our app but
rather can the user do the things that
we expect them to be able to do in our
application so testing CSS using this
idea is way more resilient to change
than using screenshots because we're
targeting very specific parts of our
code and the tests live on in another
way than then screenshots because
screenshots are kind of great and throw
away you don't build up the tests with
using using screenshots really so these
are saved in your code bases but it's a
big big con to having to write
expectations in code because that's not
how you work with visuals it's more
natural to like sit and fiddle in chrome
and try and change those colors and
experiment with your margins and so on
it would be madness to write these tests
beforehand
like I want five pixels of margin and I
have no idea what it looks like but
that's what I want and also of course
style rules are not the same thing as
looks because the site can still look
look wrong in different browsers on
different platforms than what you
intended and you're not testing that but
but as you as you here already there are
a couple of tools that you can use and
they all have different different like
use cases depending on what your problem
is you can choose pick and choose from
from all these and maybe you can use all
of them so so this kind of should be
good news to everyone right this is good
but let me ask you this how many of you
are in like a serious way using any of
these tools hands up and maybe there is
like two guys over there but it mostly
looks like this and why is that we have
tools maybe people are just not aware of
them maybe you had never heard of them
before so that's good I'm here telling
you about them but if you haven't heard
of them that probably means that people
are not that into them they're not
really using them in other places either
because then you would have heard of it
so something's wrong here and I think
this is my opinion but I think that CSS
is like in between two different
disciplines we have the developers who
are very strict
we're like everything is supposed to be
in nice little boxes and possible to
describe and dismantle in a very precise
way and then we have the designers who
are more about creating so there's some
missing piece here and what is it like
what is it that we have to change to
make these things usable in my opinion
it's about design first because CSS is
just a tool to realize your designs so
we should think how do we incorporate a
design first perspective into testing
what we're doing
so let's look back at the the testing
circle when we typically work with tests
we write the test that fails we
implement the code to make it work and
then we start refactoring to make
everything great my suggestion when it
comes to testing CSS is that we start by
creating the design we want because
that's the that's the purpose of of CSS
to have a design and then when we have
that design implemented in actual HTML
looking the way we want to in at least
one browser in in one news case then we
start to ensure the consistency across
browsers and devices and we also look at
the compatibility with the rest of our
code did we break something when we
created this new page and added new
styles or is everything else still
working and when we have done that when
we have ensured consistency and
compatibility then we can start
eliminating redundancy if we have a way
to automatically rerun that step and
this is this is actually mapping exactly
to this but it's the design that is the
test we need a way to make sure that the
design we have created becomes the test
the test is not something of its own and
then implementing the code that's not
about writing your first CSS making
making it show up in the browsers that's
about consistency across browsers and
compatibility with the rest of your code
because you all know that right
creating a design is not hard and
implementing it in CSS for one browser
in one use case that's easy the big job
is the the laggard browsers like getting
it work to work in ie6 like that's half
of the album at least and then the
mobile devices and everything so the
real work is done in number two and then
we can think about how do we eliminate
redundancies but we should not do some
magic new type of tests before
everything the design is the test
so let's talk about a possible fifth
option here we're thinking about this
again imagine that we have written
something like this we have a scenario
describing exactly what the user can do
and that tests that this is possible and
if you don't have this then I'm not
really sure that you should be worried
about whether your site looks right or
not because you have no idea if it's
working so you should start in that end
that's my opinion at least so start by
making sure your site works by using
selenium and cucumber capybara any of
those things and now we have user
stories we have descriptions of all the
things that the user can do in our
application so we don't have to do that
like manual recording for things we want
to test we already have the descriptions
of what we want to test and now the
question that remains is does it look
right
during those steps in our tests and well
how is the computer supposed to know if
it looks right because even if all the
browser's look exactly the same
maybe they often look like [ __ ] so this
is is creating the test you have written
something and now we want to say that
this is the thing this is the way I want
it to look this is working so just
imagine that we've created some simple
site like this and we had some some
plug-in or some bookmarklet in our site
that we could click on to say that now
this is right this looks like I want it
to look because you can't let the
computer decide if the looks is correct
or not but this browser at this
particular time with exactly this source
code this is what I want now we can
shove that away put put it in the cloud
do do screenshots do Dom sniffing use
all technologies there are two to
capture this state that the application
is in in
that browser and now we have to start
checking other browsers and see if the
rest of our app works well that's not
that hard because we already have tools
that do that given that would capture
the state like I told you before so we
could we could automatically run the
same tests in all other browsers using
selenium and all versions and so on and
all devices and see in how this was not
very clear but we can still get some
kind of list saying that in these four
you have deviations that look very
different from what you already what you
already have and we could show them and
guide the user to see where where are
the faults and since since we since we
based the tests on I'm jumping back now
but to on these things and these are
saved all the scenarios in our
applications are stored in our code base
when we run this thing we will also know
if all the other things that we had
before are still working the way they
used to before we wrote our new code so
now we just have to go through this in
kind of the same way that you would do
with image diffs to mark the diffs and
say that this change is intended and
this change is not intended and maybe
certain TV ange deviations that are not
intended changes but our rendering
differences and so on you can you can
mark them as okay as well if you think
that it's okay that it looks this way in
this browser and when you've resolved
everything it all passes everything is
green and the test tool now tells you
that everything works so now you can go
to the third step and you can start
moving CSS around you can start deleting
attributes that you think are are dead
and so on and you can see does this test
still pass does it produce the same
thing
so to kind of get the gist of this the
idea is that the sign is manual
you can't automate the sign you have to
you have to create some layout and the
definition of correct that's also manual
it's in the same way that you're writing
your tests in in JavaScript for
JavaScript is manual then defining what
is the right look that's also manual you
have to do that yourself that's your job
but testing changes that's automatic and
can be done using various different
technologies that we have further down
the stack so it's about design first and
design as tests not tests as some
separate entity and if we look at the
the ups and downs for for this thing
what's what's the pros and what's the
cons well we're jacking into the
acceptance tests that are already there
and that's useful because it means that
there are a ton of things that we don't
have to set up we assume that acceptance
tests are there so we can somehow deploy
to a staging site we have a staging
environment that we can [ __ ] up
completely if we want to and we have
already described all the possible
scenarios that the user will go through
and like I said if you don't have that
already then then you have bigger
problems obviously so this also gives us
this thing that we don't need a record
step we already know what kind of steps
we want to go through that we want to
test and there's no convoluted the
science back saying in encode what the
design should be like but you have
looked at the design at a design and
stated that this was what I wanted this
is the way it's supposed to look now
there there's one big con to this and
it's that it's make-believe so this is
the actual mythic part of the
presentation to be honest it's not
entirely make-believe because I've been
working on something like this with a
couple of my colleagues
but it split into pieces across a number
of of proprietary code bases so it's
kind of hard to extract it we started
working on this because we want to make
a tool out of this that people can use
but I ended up getting a new job that
takes a lot of energy and I haven't had
time to finish this thing so if we look
back at at my initial idea like the the
purpose of the presentation I wanted to
to raise some awareness and I hope I've
done that you've seen a couple of tools
and you can you can also look for like
their their competition if you want to
see others but these are the types of
tools these for that are the most
popular at least and then I wanted to
inspire you to this new workflow a new
way of thinking about design and testing
that a design is correct but there's a
third thing and it's the fact that I I
feel like all these tools are hard to
get started with testing is hard to
begin with and this type of testing is
even harder but I still feel like we
have to get further we have to create
something more and make this more
accessible easier to use for everyone to
get started with it so what I would be
really happy for would be for you to
kind of join into the discussion I'm
sure a lot of you have opinions about
this you have ideas you have been things
yourselves you have faced challenges
that you think that a tool like this
wouldn't solve good or bad all kinds of
feedback can be used to take us all like
a bit further - to figure out what we
what we really need what's the next
thing and of course actually working on
it if someone were to to make a
prototype that would do something like
this without all the messy code that I
already have I I would be more than
happy so this is not my idea this is an
open idea
and you have you have my twitter handle
you have the the J's comb Twitter handle
you have the the shat on the site we
have IRC start talking everywhere start
talking about this thing and see is this
something we really need or is it just
in my mind and that's all I wanted to
say about automated CSS testing thank
you all right thank you take it and as
usual if anyone has any more questions
for Jacob just raise your hands since we
have a couple of minutes extra I have a
tiny favor to ask of you and it's it's
since the Wi-Fi is amazing at this
conference it's really great we should
do a little load test so that there's a
tiny URL down there and I see a lot of
computers and I guess a lot of you have
smartphones so if you would use one
minute to go onto that and and answer
three short questions about this thing I
would be very happy because it would
help like help us to know whether or not
we should pursue this and like finish
our idea when we find the time or if
it's like totally uninteresting hi I'm
just wondering how you'd work this into
kind of in the iterative design
environment I did you wait till the
design is finished and then build all
the tests are you kind of doing them in
parallel with your design as it's
changing
when you say designer do you mean a
person who is just making like Photoshop
mock-ups or someone who's actually
writing CSS as well to me the only valid
web designer is one who can code as well
someone who is a coding designer yeah
yeah and that's the best kind obviously
that's that's the one I would work with
so so the question was how to work it
wrestle with that kind of person like
between developer and designer yeah I
guess the thing is trying to reduce the
other hit of yeah and ideally this would
all be something that a designer could
use on his or her own like you should
not have to think about programming when
you do this mmm that's why for example
you want to get away from the writing of
a test specification and so on you want
this to just be about looking at
something and saying yeah this is what I
want and now it's correct and then a
designer who's working with CSS they can
obviously already start fiddling with
their code and see if things changes and
run this again you don't as a designer
you don't have to learn anything new to
to do this thing you just have to have
to run this tune whenever you feel like
you you're finished is it not working
everywhere and so on
so I I definitely think it would be
perfect for working iteratively yeah
well and I mean after it depends what
you mean with after I I would say that
creating the design is a small part of
the work and then making it work in all
places and with the rest of your code
that's the large work and you do it both
you do it between those steps and after
the last one as well for refactoring and
so on so it should be something that you
do continuously as soon as you you feel
like you've designed something that's
complete
but you're not sure if it works
everywhere else and with the rest of
your code
great things